-Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me, man.
This is late night "Late Night."
-This is late night
"Late Night."
-Yeah, like tomorrow.
[ Laughter ]
-I should really stress,
you have a show
at 6:00 a.m. tomorrow.
-Yeah, I got to be up at 4:2
in the morning.
-Wow. And that's every day
4:20?
-Yes. my phone tells me to get
ready for bed around 8:00.
I should be in bed by 8:20 t
get eight hours of sleep.
That never happens, but it's
the thought that counts.
-That's good.
[ Laughter ]
Your show
"The Breakfast Club" --
you have people from all walks
of life on your show.
And this year
it has become a stop
for a lot of the candidates.
-Yeah.
-You've had Harris,
Sanders, Booker, Buttigieg
-Booker, Warren, Williamson.
-Anybody surprised you?
Anybody different than wha
you expected when they came in
-I mean, I didn't have any
expectations of any of them,
to be honest with you.
-Yeah. That's helpful.
-And I think that's the best way
to approach it
when it comes to politicians
go in with no expectations
because if you have
an expectation,
you'll probably get let down
So if you have no expectations
then you'll be like,
"Oh, he's not as bad as they say
politicians are."
-Yeah, that's good.
You just look at it as a macro
-There you go. There you go.
-I imagine that
when they're on their show
you get to talk to them
about things
that they are maybe
not talking about other places
and introduce them to
an audience that they're not -
So you probably provide them
great value.
-Well, the best thing for me i
I'm not a political pundit
Like, I'm actually stupid
when it comes to politics.
So I don't know anything.
I'm just, like, a private
citizen that has a vote.
So I'm talking to them
from the perspective of,
"Why I would vote for you?
That's it. Simple, nothing else.
I don't have any vested interest
in any one party, nothing.
-That must be nice for them.
-You know what?
Let me rephrase that.
I will vote liberal this year.
Okay?
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I voted liberal
the only other two times
I voted or three times.
-You're 3 for 3?
-Yes.
-I want to ask,
this is your second book.
And you wrote this book only
18 months after your first book,
which was a bestseller.
-"The New York Times"
bestseller.
-"New York Times" bestseller
-I mean, because it could be
a bestseller at, you know,
a pharmacy somewhere.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah,
you want to make sure. Yeah.
-"New York Times" bestseller
important to say, you know
-[ Laughs ]
And did you have a plan
after your first book
to turn around 18 months later
with the second one?
-No, you know.
You know how it is?
Have you ever put a book out
-No, I haven't.
So I don't know how it is.
-Yeah, exactly.
But, you know, they'll push yo
to do a second book,
but I really wasn't in a rus
to do a second book
because I don't do
things for money.
So I don't want to do things
unless I got something to say,
and so I started going to
therapy to, like, deal wit
my anxiety and my PTSD
and my bouts of depression
and you know how it is
when you go to therapy.
Like, you're sitting there
talking to your therapist,
and they're peeling back layer
of all kind of stuff
in your life.
You're in there crying about
your father
and you didn't know
that you hated your father
but you really love your fathe
but she makes you feel lik
you hate him.
[ Laughter ]
And so it's like I started
keeping a journal of everythin
that was going on in therapy
and then I got with a doctor
named Dr. Ish because what I was
trying to do is translate
what I was experiencing
in therapy.
But what she was really making
me do is just understand
what I was feeling so I would be
able to explain my feeling
when it came to
the clinical correlations.
I got a doctor named Dr. Ish
to do that,
and it just became
the pages in that book.
-And so you're
very open and honest
about your anxiety
and depression.
You also talk about how
there's a real negative stigma
about issues like that
in the black community.
Did you feel it was really
important for you
to have that honesty with
your readers in this case?
-Yeah, I mean, for me, man
the easiest thing in the world
is to be myself.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I can't front -- Like
right now I'm tired as hell.
[ Laughter ]
I had to say that because I feel
like y'all are looking at me
and looking like,
"He really looks tired."
But really that's just
my probably anxiety.
[ Laughter ]
-We mentioned all the, you know,
Democratic candidates
you've had on the show.
Have you had
conservative candidates
or conservative pundits
on your show?
Do you like talking to peopl
like that?
We sometimes have trouble having
them come on the show becaus
they want to talk about
everything but Donald Trump.
They don't want to defend him,
and obviously it's something
we'd like to ask them.
-Kind of hard to defend that guy
at this point.
-Yeah. It's hard for us to hav
people on who support his part
without actually talking about
him because
it seems a little unfair
to divorce the two.
-Yeah, you know what's so sa
about life, man --
A lot of us can't admit we mad
a mistake.
You know what I'm saying?
And that's what I see with a lot
of Trump supporters.
They just don't want to admi
they made a mistake.
It's okay.
Just do better next year.
-Yeah, there you go.
-I just feel it's not enough
honest conversations going on.
Like, I was watching the debat
tonight,
and I was glad that Cory Booke
brought up the fact
that they have said
there was Russian interference
in our elections,
'cause me, as a voter, I'm like,
okay, in 2020, how are we gonn
know that the voting process
is fair
with all this rampant vote
suppression going on
and the fact that we know
it was Russian interference?
Like, how do we know
the fight's not fixed?
I'm glad he brought that up.
-You have a thing, Donkey of
the Day, on your show.
-Yes, that's where I give people
the credit they deserve
for being stupid.
[ Laughter ]
I kind of like that right no
for agreeing to do this show
at 1:00 in the morning.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, do you think you might be
tomorrow's Donkey of the Day
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
And if I yawn right now,
it has nothing to do with you.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel better when people yaw
during the live shows.
I really do appreciate
you making the time.
-Thanks for having me.
-I think it's great.
The platform you have
is really wonderful.
-What about Donkey of the Day?
You just wanted to
bring that up?
-Well, I was gonna say, did yo
see anything in the debate
that made you think --
Did you see any potential
Donkey of the Days there?
-No, I mean, I was disappointe
in a couple of the candidates.
You know what I'm saying?
I feet like Senator Harris
dropped the ball
a little bit tonight.
-Yep.
-Joe Biden -- I just --
I just don't think
he's good at debating.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I think, like,
he wants to be President
without doing the work.
Like, in my first book,
"Black Privilege,"
I have this rule called
"put the weed in the bag."
And it's all about the process
You know what I'm saying?
You can't skip the process
Like, you know, there's this
movie called "Belly,"
where these two kids
were sitting down
with the two stars of the movie,
DMX and Nas, and he was like
"Yo, I want to go out ther
and get money!
I want to go out there
and get money."
DMX was like, "Man, shut up an
put the weed in the bag first.
So that means you can't escape
the process.
I don't think Joe wants to
put the weed in the bag.
He just wants to go out ther
and sell the weed.
-That's an excellent point
Charlamagne tha God, everybody